the riots in Missouri have gone all the
way out to to the situation and watched
in how lawmakers and the president is
going to deal with this I feel is there
a single explanation for why local
police forces have been using
military-style equipment well Betty it's
something we've seen building for really
the last couple of decades but it kicked
into high gear post-september 11 2001
what you saw at that time was a change
in posture of local police state police
you saw grant programs on the federal
side from the Department of Homeland
Security the Department of Justice make
it more an issue Betty of not who gets
the money but how much money can we
actually give them the key thing that
people have been tracking back what's
going on in Ferguson too though betty
has been a Department of Defense program
called the 1033 program basically what
that was written into law to do is
excess material coming from the
Department of Defense can be transferred
to local police forces this is no small
deal 4.3 billion dollars in military
equipment have been transferred over the
years 450 million just in 2013 Betty a
key thing to keep an eye out for here is
as the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan have
wound down there's a lot of excess
equipment at the Pentagon in large part
that is transferred to local police
forces and that's what we've seen in
Ferguson Betty feel it hasn't just been
about the equipment being used but also
the tactics so what's changed there I
think this is what's raising the biggest
concern in Washington right now and I
think it's been jarring for anybody just
watching them images they have come out
of Ferguson it's not just that they have
militarized equipment it's how they've
been using it it's the rubber bullets
it's the use of sound cannons in gas to
push away protesters what the ACLU laid
out in a report in June has been very
interesting what we've seen local police
move toward is more SWAT like tactics
you've seen 50,000 SWAT deployments a
year on average seventy-nine percent of
those SWAT rates or just to serve search
warrants now that's not generally what
you use SWAT teams for I think the
interesting thing that people have tried
to figure out Betty is why are the
tactics going this way and if you want
to know if they work look at the change
in posture down in Ferguson just over
the last 24 hours since that
captain ron johnson came in and made
very clear that the gas masks would be
gone the use of these tactics would be
changing the police would be out in the
field with the protesters not firing
rubber bullets at them the situation has
de-escalated in a very big way and Phil
before we go what about lawmakers and
what they're saying about this Betty I
think that there's been shocked there's
been genuine shock as they've watched as
this has occurred and this actually
rolls into a political issue for them
you've seen Senator Rand Paul a
Republican from Kentucky has a bit of a
libertarian been is considered a top
Republican presidential candidate he
came out yesterday Betty with an
interesting statement said basically in
an op-ed the images and scenes we
continue to see in Ferguson resemble war
more than traditional police action he
is lining up and Democrats are coming
with them into a single kind of view
betty that this is wrong and changes
need to be made something to keep an eye
on when lawmakers come back in September